I'm nan ribbon I'm the project director
at channel 13 for a project called
preserving digital Public Television and
it's a project funded by the Library of
Congress under a program called ndi IPP
Jeff mentioned it as end if it stands
for national digital information and
infrastructure preservation program and
it's actually something that the library
created coming out of some of these
studies that they had done earlier that
were mentioned before that Jay mentioned
94 and 1994 1997 on what it was going to
take to preserve cultural information
into the future particularly digital
cultural information and especially the
report in 1997 that Mary ID from WGBH
and another number of other people
worked on specifically looking at what
it would take to preserve Television
once it really moved into the digital
environment because obviously in 97 it
was very difficult for people to even
conceive of what preservation would take
but the Library of Congress you know
being the trusted repository for our
cultural heritage was really trying to
think about that so they had money set
aside to create some pilot projects
specifically on digital preservation of
born digital material and our project
was funded several years ago to work
particularly with born digital public
television productions discrete programs
i'm going to talk just a little bit
about what that is our project is
comprised of three public television
entities channel 13 and WGBH you've
already heard from WGBH between us our
two stations are responsible for
approximately sixty percent of the
national programming schedule on public
TV the prime time excuse me the
primetime programming schedule on public
TV as it exists right now in the analog
world I think that'll be changing when
there's the digital switchover night
oh nine but right now we we do a lot of
the national programming we also have
new york university as our partner
they're very well experienced in
developing digital libraries and that's
something public TV doesn't have any
experience with so we're very happy to
be working with them they also have a
program in moving image preservation
that includes film and video and so
they've been extremely valuable in
working with us on what it takes to work
in a library and archive environment
again public television doesn't have
much experience in that kind of a world
we also are working with PBS directly
PBS is the primary distributor of public
television broadcast programs right now
and they don't hold the copyright they
don't do any of the production but they
do the acquisition and distribution for
the programs so most of the material
that's seen on public TV right now goes
to PBS and then PBS sends it out and
that's changing in a lot of different
ways but they have a collection now of
virtually all of the programs that have
been sent out over public TV from the
60s 1960s some of that material gets
deposited at the Library of Congress but
right now a lot of it is also sitting in
a warehouse in Virginia they have a
hundred and fifty thousand videotapes
there a lot of it is in 2-inch format
and one-inch format and obsolete things
that nobody can play back anymore for us
to look at without a fairly expensive
kind of transformation process so we're
going to be trying to come up with a
plan for some of that as well but you
can see the library wants to preserve
this as one of the most important
records of cultural history in the
United States and we're going to help
them out if we can our project is
specifically working on born digital
programs technically with the library of
congress money we can't really work
directly on any of the analog stuff but
we're in our planning we're encompassing
all of the materials that we hold even
though our model repository is really
for the born digital materials and we
are well along now we're at the end of
the third year of what was to be a
three-year project we've already had it
extended for two more years so we'll be
going for a while
and we are going to our supposed to be
designing a model repository for digital
video so that's what NYU is really
helping us with and even though you can
look at the stuff that we've been
looking at all day today actually
thinking about a preservation repository
for digital materials is really not as
simple as it sounds there are a lot of
steps that have to go through in order
for us to think about preparing the
material to put into a of preservation
repository and then of course the main
thing is being able to retrieve it
putting it in isn't so hard but getting
it back out again with integrity with it
being intact in the way that it was
produced and reflecting the kinds of
things that were put into it when it was
originally broadcast or produced are the
things that we're really working on the
challenges that we have been looking at
I want to say that we have a website and
we're putting a lot of our material up
there it's a little we're little slow
but we're trying to be steady on it we
have a we have a very excellent report
that was prepared on selection criteria
because we're talking about a lot of
quantity of material not just finished
programs but all the material or not all
the material but a great deal of
material that didn't go into the
programs so that would be available
possibly for non broadcast or even just
for research later and so we've got a
paper that we prepared on selection mary
was actually very instrumental in
writing that we've got a paper that were
just about ready to publish on metadata
you've heard that a couple of times now
and I was very heartened when Marie this
morning the very first presentation said
metadata is king because we feel like
it's one of the things the term is
getting to be a little overused but it's
really crucial to being able to retrieve
digital files digital files are useless
if they don't have the labels and the
labels are in the metadata we also have
a paper on file formats and I'm not sure
that people understand in the production
of broadcast video we probably I haven't
counted them up we probably go through
uh no no help me Mary or Karen
we could easily have like 50 different
file formats that the programs the
program material the audio the
animations the text etc get when they're
getting move back and forth between one
editing system to another editing system
to something that puts them on a file
format and kicks them back out for some
other use and moves them around to
another place there's a lot of file
formats that are used there and there's
a lot of information that gets put into
them and stripped out and put in again
and in order for us to be successful
with the preservation aspects we've got
to be mindful of all those and try and
protect that information as much as
possible and this of course is where the
whole idea of standards comes in and
also streamlining the production process
so we're working on publishing our
analysis of what it takes to actually
produce a television program as it's
done right now for broadcast and what
it's going to take for us to distribute
that program in a digital form and to
preserve that program in a digital form
we're looking at one of the major
technical problems is a file wrapper
which is what it's going to take for us
to package the essence which is the
actual moving image material with the
metadata in some kind of a format so
that we can put it in a repository and
retrieve it that's why our paper on file
formats and metadata we're going to try
to mash them up together to actually
move forward on that we thought that
other TV producers would be working on
the problem of file of the file wrapper
and so we went around and talked to the
networks etc nobody was doing it we
actually found that we were kind of out
there by ourselves so we organized a
meeting with the support of the Library
of Congress a year ago and we invited a
lot of people working on file format
particularly video file format issues to
talk to us about rappers and we also
asked for the help of PBS which was
developing its own kind of a rapper and
we found that everyone said oh we'll
work with
or we'll follow you so instead of us
being able to kind of do follow along
with what was being developed in the
commercial world we're finding that
commercial folks were ready to follow us
so two things have developed out of that
one is that PBS is actually developing
an mxf profile for video files for use
for distribution that's going to be
specifically oriented for public
television because we were finding with
all of the so-called definition of mxf
being so flexible all of that that in
fact some of the mechanisms that were
playing back our files were stripping
out the closed captioning obviously not
a good thing so we needed to protect
that we needed to protect some of the
information we're coming up with our own
profile for mxf which we hope will then
be adopted as a standard and that will
help us greatly with the
interoperability we also have recently
joined up with Turner Broadcasting
discovery and some of the other cable
broadcast networks to work collectively
on rapper that we'd be able to use
through the production format that again
we hope would be adopted as a standard
within television so that we'll all be
able to use the same material we get the
vendors to promise that they'll be able
that they will in fact playback whatever
we give them and one other thing that
we're working on now is that we're
starting to archive all the websites in
public television this is something very
recent that we're doing in cooperation
with the Internet Archive we felt that
with all of the companion websites that
were developed for public TV and now
that we're seeing a lot of public TV
developing out of the websites that we
should be capturing those things and
also putting them into some kind of a
preservation environment or at least
storing them in a way that we have a
historical record of these things
particularly because people seen the TV
programs at some point will also want to
know what was online and connect
connection with these things so we're
just starting to do this and we're
actually very excited about it and
hopefully we'll have something to be
able to show people soon where they
want to start looking at the history of
doing it now you know we won't up too
much history but if we do it over a
period of time we know that it'll be
there a new development which has come
out of all of these various efforts with
us with our partners within ended and
also we have a group of fellow travelers
people from a bunch of other public
television stations and independent
producers is this concept of the
American archive which was mentioned
earlier this morning at Zoo Kantrowitz
from GBH brought up the American archive
is actually a very new development and
it's partially the inspiration of the
British creative archive it's partially
coming out of some of the work that's
been done within public broadcasting by
the Corporation for Public Broadcasting
organized a digital rights working group
basically to say what do we do to start
managing our material in a way that we
can make it accessible to the public
also the development of a standard for
providing descriptive metadata called PB
core which is based on the library
standard called dublin core and it's an
expansion of that that's been in the
works for a couple of years it was
finally released and now we're trying to
encourage TV stations around the country
to use it because it's a standard the
mic website will map to PB core and it's
something that we feel like is really
important that's out there now and
something that's also very important
which is also fairly recent is the
extension of the public broadcasting
distribution system which has been a
kind of 1.2 many system up until
recently in the analog design and is now
in the process of being transformed into
a digital distribution system which will
be based on very broadband access to
program files and will be not just one
point too many but also will involve
peer-to-peer distribution and that's in
the process of being planned and we
found that in looking at the existing
infrastructure and public broadcasting
which we have extensive infrastructure
nationally
which is all being transformed into
digital infrastructure that we could
include a preservation element in that
as well so that in addition to having
programs available for play out for
public play out over broadcasting that
we could capture some of that and be
able to store it for long-term
preservation as well and that that we
can use the existing system to plan how
that would work and the American archive
is based in part on taking advantage of
that digital infrastructure that's being
put in place and in large part also on
of course the growing interest on having
these access to these materials that
people have on their shelves that all of
a sudden is a hot commodity old TV it's
a hot commodity and not only do we have
the 150,000 national programs that PBS
has on their shelves every local station
has their own local programs on the
shelves that are historical documents
that are really important so the
American archive if we're successful
will be able to begin making some of
these materials available and the focus
of a lot of that is educational access
we prepared a little promo reel to sell
this idea when we when it was first
brought to Congress a couple of weeks
ago actually a couple of months ago and
I thought we could show that to you now
back in 1952 the Regents of the
University of Wisconsin called for the
establishment of a television laboratory
at the beginning of a new and wonderful
element of the cultural life of our city
tonight you join me in being present at
the birth of a great adventure if
newness be its vice than boldness the
its virtue let's look in the window to
inclusion who's in here anyhow he can
win them hey it's you
I like wonders of the vehicle
you can sing welcome to the French chef
I'm Julia Child national Educational
Television presents the wgbh TV
production mrs. Eleanor Roosevelt
prospects of mankind mr. president go
very kind indeed
a future in which our country will match
its military strength
without moral restraint
forever young
so I've got rid of varna Cucaracha bingo
a member
would you be willing to vote for
something stronger than that would have
meaning to all these people who've been
sitting here what percentage of the
plainclothesman assigned to the division
to the 6th division at that time do you
feel participated in the pad have you
went to my knowledge everyone everyone
now we got the interest bills the diesel
taxes empty tax and auto emissions don't
be a busy afternoon
every time you hear us say the two words
all seven you respond with San Diego
cybersquad is back in business
Oh
that's our propaganda piece for trying
to express the importance of us
preserving this material and making it
accessible to people though we have a
lot of problems to overcome in order to
really do this obviously we've talked
about a few of them or you've heard
about a few the rights clearances being
able to go back and actually get
adequate cataloguing and a lot of this
material the technical remastering of
the old stuff which can be quite costly
and some kind of real access mechanism
so that there'll be an interface that
people would be able to use but these
are all things that we think will be
getting support from the Corporation for
Public Broadcasting to begin planning
and we'll have a lot of support
throughout the public broadcasting
system both television and radio to
start working on this kind of a project